sorry welcome to this video playing if
you do Master draw hot chick oh he's
going with the Smith Moria that's bloody
let's decline it I really don't feel so
well in them accepted and down my
experience is that and quite often the
decline Smith mora with d3 while being
maybe slightly better for white does it
really yeah it doesn't really am lead to
positions that the typical Smith moral
player does enjoy so what about this
here I can already trade off tons of
stuff here i wonder if that is an idea
like Bishop see 395 hmm that is pretty
interesting okay let's do this I'm not a
huge fan usually off of this this kind
of trade but it makes some some sense in
this position yeah this is this is clear
that this was was in but i thought that
i'm pretty pretty okay here with this
kind of thing teak now while Bishop g7
is a bit annoying
it looks weird to take that yeah I think
I have to actually and get this get this
regrouped so that Bishop g7 is not
involved in a double attack let's say on
rook enter at night my dear now is Queen
a five maybe queen age five yes but i
can go f6 that's really not a big issue
dad has always some kind of risk
involved in this operation with this
capture on c3 but i think objectively
speaking i should be in a very decent
shape quincy seven not sure let's over
protect you five for one more moment and
Quincy five can be interesting at least
form some kind of tempo gain as you
probably will have to play King edge one
at some point have whoopsie a time isn't
this how is he not losing see for now is
it some kind of if I form maybe no
ah you know what he had instead of rugby
five he had Bishop g7 rook g 8 25 that
would have been very embarrassing who
are long castles maybe maybe I can play
home castles but that was entirely
unplanned whoa shaky game yeah and now
what now just Quincy 525 yeah this is
actually pretty good i believe he cannot
really take that would be basically
giving up and he have queen age five and
the bishop is in some distress i believe
how is he not losing this piece I think
I'll just win it
Bishop g7 Ruby eight it is completely
trapped yeah this is them the only only
real try here so what now I can actually
think of just
let's let's let's consider I can take g7
and if it takes d6 I can go e 6 there it
looks like some compensation actually
okay I'm doing this that's a pragmatic
choice just taking the horn and set over
the piece and make sure that this is
very simple to play now yep can easily
do this and now play with the pawn up
and no problems whatsoever
now maybe I should have taken the piece
but this seems seems pretty good okay um
night back maybe 496 yeah here I was
thinking I know be six or five maybe six
Jack ok and now how to get pressure here
maybe like this rookie three he's got
plenty of weaknesses to attack that's
the nice thing about this production I
do this c5 mmm anything better maybe not
sure no will see 5 is 2 points up
ultimately
okay let's let's make some room there on
g6 so that at the end of a c5 related
line if he checks me on c7 that I can go
to g6 that would be quite helpful I
don't really see how we can avoid c5
anyway dropping the second porn I made
me look before you okay let that that
you can probably do okay this is also
also possible so let's gain some space
c4 c5 is I'm dropping the a to pawn
now I can think about and now it would
always check no even if white as
possible it's an interesting idea 1 95
94 that is a pretty good alternative not
sure what's better time morning and this
is the problem kind of spending a bit
too much of time him it's probably just
taking it allowing the night 34 is
probably not a very wise decision ok so
right over here no I don't my dad one
let's see maybe over 2 g-3 but not sure
it's it's good anyway check check
check hmm it wasn't as Josh a great
decision check a bit premature what I
did them
okay not not great didn't play that well
check
check check before B to maybe check
ok this is check some progress asia 3 is
hanging and this age three and a two
were saying some I'm not sure it wasn't
terribly resign the best possible
technical play but yeah yes some always
the thymus you yeah okay well probably I
should have taken the piece there but
here you know I mean I can probably just
really take it but now I can't really
take it on this this and now grabbing is
pretty safe actually I'm threatening to
take with the noid so any rookie 10 so i
can play night 65 and if he takes this
night x i will castle next move so it's
pretty simple yeah i mean this end game
should ultimately win as well but as we
have seen it it takes a long while and I
can be all kinds of problems with the
clock and your own technical
shortcomings j.chan yeah I'm not sure
maybe I JD's a job it's check check
30-something seconds it's tough to check
tough to be sure tough to be sure yeah
that's actually a word or a sanchez
check Jim I'm not sure if he could have
saved it at some point him here it looks
chad brooks III s bailout cam Brooks III
is better I still intend to do this
traffic I know he can check me here
right this is probably not leading to
anything if I'm going back here he has
this yeah you know that's it's probably
a draw now that's it wrong yeah I didn't
play that too well that's okay well it's
it's a it's a time thing okay well
thanks for watching